[Music]
what do you dream for that less people
have to say goodbye too soon to people
they love the story is incredible from
Tech Superstar to prison inmate this is
new video former therano CEO Elizabeth
Holmes wearing jeans and reporting to a
federal prison camp today to begin
serving her 11-year sentence will it be
easy time that she's doing it's going to
be a cubicle with two to eight people
inside of that that cubicle so you're
living amongst other women and that
comes down to something Elizabeth Holmes
needs to embrace right they're going to
be is she hygienic is she clean is she
loud is she noisy the mother of two who
was convicted of defrauding the
investors of a blood testing startup was
spotted out at a gas station last month
near her home in San Diego this balloon
was in her front window yesterday it
said world's best mom there's visits
that will happen once to twice a month
and fortunately in the female camps
there's video chats she's able to visit
with her family for 15 minutes in a
video chat
I'm anticipread Amanda Seyfried who won
an Emmy playing the disgraced CEO in the
Dropout appeared on GMA today I feel for
those kids there's two kids that are
hanging in the balance life's not fair
but in a lot of ways it's fair yeah for
her in particular Elizabeth is at the
same prison as Jen Shaw from The Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City this
morning I spoke to Jen's attorney Justin
papurni do you think there's a chance
that her and Elizabeth will run into
each other there's a guarantee if
they're going to run into one another
and there's also going to be an
understanding amongst them so for that
reason I suspect they'll connect they
may become friends there was a photo
taken of Jen in the yard at prison and
she said it was an invasion of privacy I
think it's true people aren't supposed
to be taking photos but that is the
brown outfit that Elizabeth Holmes will
be wearing you are required to wear that
Monday to Friday from morning till
evening